yeah welcome to this video playing cilia
withered from the u.s. don't really know
to see no name but I rated 25 something
okay let's play the this Bogle Catalan
mixture then I'm writing the book about
but ok I am I'm not yet at this chapter
so just playing this um um yeah well
basically making it up during during
play I only know that I will look at
this line but not the details ok yeah
well I know what I know is Bishop g5 is
a move and this is also move it's
threatening a three-to-two em to trap my
bishop and maybe you can play p3p should
be to later
yeah black black some plan is something
like this mmm wait this is this is
rarely played the sauce f3e for stuff
maybe i can i can play for c65 but i
want to activate first is the Bishop c5
now why not and maybe a form some useful
move
mm-hmm I wonder is a foreign idea man
probably nonsense let's just get on with
normal moves Queen B 6 are also useless
should I play yes a bit of nothing moves
before 27 okay let's prevent Bishop to
g5 and see how to continue i'm not quite
sure it does look bad for black or
anything but I'm not so sure how to how
to exactly continue one way to play some
just something like that Bishop d7 rook
the eighth bishop see it back to get the
rooks in the center is this a threat
know what don't think so one age six i
mean i don't i don't think so
I want to go bishop CA this is quite
smooth both rooks in the center now and
I can after that to decide how to
continue
yeah I want to get get some of the C
file this is not too comfortable yeah
Bishop a 700-ton Quincy three or
something okay I need to retreat this is
some I'm not sure actually maybe I am
could have thought about this just for a
moment you don't necessarily always need
to drop back here so is there some
whopper t5 now that I look at this why
not d5 night f5 it's not the problem
yeah then d5 why not got every
everything's in the center so maybe I
can take a place c5 I have some tactical
shots nights ii 4g for stuff like that
but i'm not sure that k is not going for
that oh what's this all night f5 this is
a nice move oh nice
nice yep this one but is there is there
is there something like which is seven
cakes right now I've got all kinds of
stuff hanging
hmm yeah Queenie six
yeah come on let's play move there's
some way at least to get some counter
play maybe b5 any way to look these six
this is thread maybe it is maybe you can
go here and take a form does this have
made also also not really a good cannot
take you for gas was a very nice shot
wotty wot you fall down the Sun with
this rook c8
hmm no way for nothing nothing maybe
looked towards my hope I can take you to
you can just take it unnie oh no I can
take and still working I've got 93 if
you move for the Queen a flight g3 check
and mate on g2 but you can take the rook
this is the problem and now after this
it's it's a bit of sometimes it just
happens that those pure you're lost and
nothing's nothing's working ok just
besides yeah yeah this was strong yeah I
didn't see this at all then he had d5
took rook c8 yeah it is strong the
computer disagrees it sinks rook c8 is
so good for black uh-huh I because
Bishop Bishop d4 of course a text the
Queen oh my hmm yeah this is bad yeah
then rook takes the edge was just
nonsense at least it's not particularly
great can I can take addends didn't
consider this Bishop takes rook takes
tonight v6 guy again it's a white can
can fight of course but it's not not in
that form foreign exchange some
compensation but not enough this means
that like a San in good shape here after
d5 go on I mean all pieces look fine the
only bad thing about this position was
this loose be sure Bonnie's heaven and
this is what Luke c8 was all about and
simply blunders not seeing
to take on default yeah thanks for
watching